how's it going bros my name is pete
today we're doing another classic horror
game play
yeah exciting this is the internet's new
creepypasta obsession siren head you
might you may have heard about it i've
seen that one tick tock and i went ooh
spooky god damn that is creepy
jesus
i don't know about you guys but kind of
hot default dance
[Laughter]
ruined instantly
all right so there's a couple of siren
head games out i know there were some
controversy with one of them
of who made it earn some credit i
haven't looked into it so i hope people
don't get mad
i just want to play games that's what i
do so here we go this is siren head and
oh my god
it's dark thank you i have the g-force
overlay god damn this reminds me of
slender
so much because it was the same thing
it was a cree slender was a creepy pasta
for a long time
and then it just became uh oh this is
really [ __ ] creepy
and then someone made a game all that
and it just blew up
okay i can see a little bit more god
it's dark i can't see anything
i can't control my flashlight oh god i
hate the woods
they scare me so much oh i got
goosebumps this is not good
i'm just gonna go here what's the worst
thing that can happen a giant man
with siren head oh okay that's the worst
thing got it
maybe he's nice who knows maybe he's
just oh god oh no
[Music]
all right we're just gonna keep going
i'm not scared oh god he's right there
oh god he's right there i'm not going
there
there's a fence save me fence
i don't
[Music]
oh i'm going in the woods all right i'm
safe here right
oh god it's the tree shaking or is it my
head
it's the ice cream truck guys don't
worry that's just how it sounds like
i don't think this is good
[Music]
am i safe here i'm going i'm going
i'm going stop it
i crashed
let's do it again all right that was
fine so creepy dude
so can you go in the woods you can't
really
i thought you were supposed to escape in
that thank you nvidia for nothing
you did nothing except the rtx that
looks terrible
i said it stupid branch in my face
all right come on i'm not i'm not scared
i'm not even scared
not at all i felt like the the road went
into two different
forks is that how you say that is that
how you english
and i picked the wrong one so we're just
gonna go the other way
and everything will be fine can i run
can i do something
oh there's something here there's
something here it's a well no it isn't
well well well okay it isn't what the
flip there's campers i can't see
anything stop it
all all right bring it you think i'm
scared of you
oh god that's creepy
[Music]
i don't want any ice cream
all right we're running slow hey
cool i'll just go this way i wasn't
going that way anyway that's fine
we're fine
[Music]
yeah yeah you just want a friend look
how sad it becomes
this reminds me of physics class when
you study why the ambulance sounds light
louder when it
travels towards you or the notes i mean
sounds higher
is how it is i forgot my physics class
yeah the wavelengths get stretched out
when it passes you so that's how it
works with siren head all right i'll go
this way
this is great no sirens no peepee
in my poo i'm 30 years old i'm so sorry
okay all right
that's fine
[Music]
stop
stop where i can't even
go faster
[Music]
ah god damn it's so creepy
i have one more game there's one more
siren head game that i really want to
play it looks really cool
uh but i want to read up on some
creepypasta first just to get in the
mood
oh wait what yeah i've seen this fallout
4
mod that's so cool is that where it
originated
wait there okay oh
alert shoot this morning saturday
october 23rd
authorities detected that a nuclear
attack had commenced against the united
states god damn that's creepy
washington d.c new york philadelphia
and boston oh he just killed a b dude
what an axel so he's an artist from
toronto
don't say which artist it's a 40-foot
creature
and it's five-minute indie game capture
the heart my heart has been captured
hasn't been captured before you guys
so is this the artist that drew a siren
head yeah trevor henderson's the
original creator
it's four months ago jesus am i slow or
what i'm a 24 year old
soldier and after what happened to me i
had an uncontrollable fear of sirens
every saturday i feel like i
heard about this before every saturday
night at camp i can hear screams that
only i can hear i wake up my friends
sometimes just to see the reaction and
maybe
figure out a solution about it maybe
check it out or something but they never
heard a thing
every time i hear those screams they're
either a man or a woman
or a child scream but there's something
peculiar about them
it has this quite noticeable static
sound every time someone screams
or should i say whenever scream plays
it sounds like it's coming out of a
siren and it wakes me up every night
i learned to ignore it and i thought
it's probably just me imagining things
since i didn't like sirens that much as
a kid either too loud to be enjoyable it
wakes me up every night
and it sounds very realistic so i
thought i should ask the headmaster if
our sirens accidentally play those weird
sounds at night next morning i talked to
him about it and he said that it may
have been an error but even if it was
the signs were turned off at night only
the alarm ones
were on i tried to get him to look
deeper into this thing because i doubt
it was just an error and i was sure it
was coming from a siren
but he said he thinks i'm talking
nonsense and sent me to do some
exercises with the other soldiers
he might have been right i maybe was
just a bit paranoid this night the
sounds weren't that loud
it sounded as if it was playing from
somewhere inside the forest
i couldn't take it anymore i had to
check it out i grabbed a flashlight a
shotgun
and sneaked out a camp to go into the
forest and investigate
i know i may sound like a dumbass for
doing this like going out of
camp to check it out but those screams
were making my sanity fall apart
i kept walking and walking nothing was
found
but i could hear the sounds getting
louder i was sure i was approaching it
you're approaching me i ended up in a
straight dirt road
then i saw something it was too dark to
see but i could see something really
freaky in the dark
it was in the middle of the road so i
pointed my flashlight on it and there it
was a slim monster
that was about as tall as a tree having
long arms that could reach its toes and
for a head two sirens connected into a
tube
it looked very skinny as if it was only
bones but you could clearly see some
flesh on it
and it had metallic wires going through
its body i was terrified but without a
second thoughts
i immediately held my gun and shot it it
didn't die
but the bullet marks were clear and i
could see some blood running down but
instead of showing signs of pain
it started walking towards me without
any second thoughts i ran the opposite
direction from where i was facing
the siren mimicked my scream and played
it again oh that's so creepy
the static sounds always get me feeling
in my stomach
but from close up it was more terrifying
it then started to play
some other weird sounds coming from its
iron such as tornado warnings amber
alert announcement
and generally announced sir speaking
about scary things such as murders
criminal escapes and other messed up
stuff
i could run really fast but even though
it was walking it wasn't that far
away from me let's say i was far enough
for it to not catch me i grabbed my gun
again
stopped and shot a siren the sound it
was playing were glitched out i managed
to outrun it but it started approaching
me pretty quick
i was far enough but i could still see
in the dark i was running for about half
an hour felt more like an eternity
our distance didn't even change by a
centimeter it felt like i was running on
an infinite road
luckily i could see a car though someone
was there whoever it was i needed them
to get away from that thing
but to my disappointment it was long big
mistake stopping
the monster was now a bit closer and the
road got really bloody so it slowed me
down oh that's so creepy
i got out of the road and got inside the
forest it didn't come in
i could see it facing at me but it's not
moving i saw my camp
i was relieved but still scared to stop
and relax i asked the guards to let me
in
and since they knew me they obviously
opened the door they asked me what i was
doing outside this lane and how did i
get out
i apologized and asked them to keep it
secret but i later explained to them
what i saw and how i felt
they probably felt sorry for me and
thought that i was being paranoid
so they told me to get some rest i swore
to them i didn't lie for what i had seen
they still didn't believe me i shrugged
it up and went back to bed
that night i was so terrified it was the
most scary experience i ever had
around 5-6 a.m i woke up to sounds of
screams and subtle smell of smoke
i came outside to see what woke me up
everything was on fire
towers were torn apart and i could see
piles of dead bodies
the thing that caught my eyes though was
what i had seen some hours ago
that tall skinny siren head monster it
was responsible for everything
soldiers begged me to help them but i
could do nothing about it they were
literally torn in half
the monster saw me and reached out to
grab me it missed
the whole camp was on fire i even
wondered if i was in hell
i ran and i ran it chased me but never
stopped running
after running for so long i came to the
end of the cliff and now that there was
light i saw the monster more clearly
and now it was more terrifying than
before it stopped walking
i'd hear a crispy yet soothing voice
coming out of the siren
do you like heights mark how could this
monster know my name
this had to be a never-ending nightmare
but it was reality
come to me i begged the monster not to
kill me i cried and i asked it to leave
me alone
to my surprise it left not sure if it
regrets its decision or just wanted to
get revenge later
as i watched it turn around and
disappear into the woods
i felt relieved that i escaped out of
the situation
i went back to camp just to see all
those dead bodies and broken buildings
but i had to call someone or i wasn't
leaving this place i'm always carrying
my cell phone so i called 9-1-1 and told
them
to come to the camp address when they
arrived they told me to explain
everything
what happened and how i survived it i
described everything by detail
but they thought i was joking and told
me to act serious i told them i was
and they finally took it seriously sort
of they said they'd investigate this
i packed my stuff and they brought me
back to the city i went back home and
was happy to see my wife and kids
they were surprised i came so early i
was supposed to come five months later
i explained to my wife what had happened
and she just wouldn't believe me
she said i probably needed some rest and
got all this [ __ ] out of my crazy
imagination
all this makes me curious am i living in
a nightmare was i actually paranoid
whatever it was it's done for now
i pushed the curtains aside and opened
the window to get some fresh air
i looked outside it felt good to be home
but what i saw in the distance
made me feel shocked that monster was on
top of a building really far away
i tried to ignore it and went to get
some sleep i probably need to book a
therapy session
that was really creepy it's a cool
creepypasta gets you in the mood man
it seems like people are just jumping in
to become like the next slender
i mean at least slender had gameplay
i'll give them that you know all right i
have another game let's play that one
okay here we go
different art style this feels relaxing
i like this i'm not scared at all i got
freaking dude very aesthetic all right
we go in here oh we go in here
all right the strategy not dad
not dead
it's probably just an ambulance in the
middle of the woods
oh god stop i found it i found the
backpack guys
oh god why is that so creepy stop
no no no
oh okay it's a scrap of shirt looked
like there was struggle
story of my shirts right there who wears
them am i right gamers
tucked in t-shirt every time what
happened here nothing
nothing oh god that's fine
that's just uh that's just dirt come on
if you're scared of dirt then you're
dirt yourself dirt that's an underrated
video game right there
dirt 3 is my favorite all right we got
something happening over here
very nice it's a tree it's at a tree
it's literally just a tree
and more red dirt which is common around
woods i hear red dirt yeah absolutely
red durst has some red dirt that's
normal as well
i got to get back to the truck now
stop stop stop
oh god he's coming
i don't like radio you're dead you're
supposed to be dead
you're old media
did he say scientific scientifically
accurate
wouldn't be epic if you just dropped
like a pewdiepie reference
how's it going bros all right we're fine
he's slow i don't have to look i don't
have to run that's a celebius
what a dummy what a stinky dummy brain
a stinky brain filled with them all
right truck i'm here
and that's how the cookie crumbles in
your butt baby let's go
yeah speed running
that's it right i told you i'm pro
[Laughter]
oh god that was creepy i guess you only
really have these
sort of small games for now it's
interesting though i feel like this uh
creepypasta is really gonna blow up it's
already weird fan art
siren head approves it was the same
thing with slender
the story about slenderman kept changing
you know people came up with different
ideas
he abducts kids or he does this or that
and it always changed like what does he
do what is he
it's all just based in people's mind i
think that's fun
how the internet does that hey we got
some siren head facts
looks like he hasn't eaten it in a while
oh god but why
fuse with dried skin it's a pretty cool
concept
surprisingly effective will remain
motionless while hunting that's so
creepy
seen in rural town areas and in heavily
wooded areas
i want to see what's the first drawing
he did of siren head
because he draws a ton of different
stuff see that's terrifying
that's so
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
yeah of course in the cars
that's truly terrifying wait what is
this i fixed my camera it was only the
system broken elsa
i decided to come back again and show
you the place
whoa
this place is under control by the
government i don't know what is
happening
and what they are planning there with my
headphones it sounds crazy
they rumble like oh god i started to
hear white noise sounds when
i arrived and i saw something behind the
trees oh no
oh my god where
where i don't see it oh that's just a
pole thank god
i thought that was iron head but
that's creepy goddamn
this is creeping me out dude
the idea that he can play different
things to you is really creepy
it reminds me of the pt
when the radio play stuff based on uh
where you are like i remember playing pt
and he played swedish
radio broadcast and i'm like what the
[ __ ] what the flock yeah
that really freaked me out
oh jesus
oh my god jesus see i'm such a [ __ ] god
damn it that was great dude golden lane
studio well done
that's so cool oh he has another one
this is part one
did i watch part two first
oh it's his computer animated yeah it
must be
[Applause]
oh god
[Applause]
no i don't want another jump scare
and here my camera broke i never saw
something like this before well no
shoot he almost got me god damn
all right so that's the siren head
pretty much summarized as it is right
now uh
curious to see how this is gonna
transform on the internet with people
contributing different artists and
different stuff if you enjoyed this
video so go ahead and subscribe i upload
every day almost
smash like subscribe see you tomorrow
bye-bye in a world
where science knows no boundaries
travel to land where no tuber has been
and explore never before seen landscapes
encounter beings that are extinct
meet mayan edgar's ancestors collect
ancient items rediscover
your favorite scientifically accurate
dinos
what will you create